[Música]
estamos fuera del campamento el
campamento se como ayer y todos los
refugiados subimos el fuego fue un
incendio realmente grande y casi todo el
campamento se quemó no sabemos a dónde
ir y todos los refugiados están afuera y
tratando de encontrar un lugar donde
poder quedarse
[Música]
por ahora lo perdimos todo como estoy
aquí me quedo así no tengo nada nada
conmigo y sin embargo no sabemos dónde
vamos a dormir nuestra casa se
desvaneció nuestra comida se desvaneció
todo nuestro dinero se ha ido no sabemos
qué va a pasar
[Música]
se anima
parís y en mi vida de esta manera porque
estaba muy triste tengo demasiados
problemas pero no es normal un ser
humano no debería hacer esto pero de qué
otra manera podemos hacerlo
[Música]
hay demasiada gente viviendo en el
bosque y en la estación de tren sin
comida sin bebida sin instalaciones sin
espacio y uno el clima es muy fresco
usar un abrigo es imposible para mí para
todos porque el clima es tan frío
muchos chicos aquí están enfermos
demasiados problemas
[Música]
el corredor nos quitó el dinero y nos
hizo esperar siete meses luego compró un
bote pequeño y nos pusimos a navegar
pero nos abandonaron y luego de flotar
por varios meses llegamos a esta zona
[Música]
nosotros somos jóvenes salvajes no para
una potencial como estados unidos y
canadá salimos de haití si uno tiene
siete meses en camino por favor todo uno
tenía en la mano se gasta todo tú dices
barato no es mi país sin nada en mi mano
no va a ser bien
[Música]
en condiciones horribles mire como se
nos mojó todos los colchones anoche
cuando yo tuvimos que salir a la
madrugada por ello a buscar dónde donde
dormir
[Música]